Those who have studied the various anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation know that
this world has quite a lot to fear.
Enormous world-devouring monsters that thrive
on an endless stream of hate, seemingly innocuous
statues waiting to snap your neck the second
your turn your back, and a shark-eyed old
man with the power to reach through solid
concrete, grab hold of your with his rotting
hands, and drag you into his own personal
hell.
SCP-106 can pop into our world whenever he
wants, but like many of the most efficient
predators, he has his own designated lair,
a pocket dimension where he can pull his prey
and trap them in a horrifying game of cat
and mouse that only ever ends one way: in
a painful, prolonged end.
We all know what SCP-106 uses his pocket dimension
for, but what if some of the other anomalies
at the Foundation had a pocket dimension of
their very own?
A tiny, parallel reality that they could shape
in their image, use for whatever they wanted?
What might that look like?
A special team of SCP Foundation operatives
were tasked with conducting an experiment,
using an elaborate computer system to run
simulations and see what different anomalies
might do with their pocket dimensions, should
the opportunity ever arise.
Stranger things have certainly happened at
the SCP Foundation.
So, they prepared a list of anomalies that
presented the most potential for interesting
findings, and fired up the simulation.
For the very first subject, they selected
an anomaly who was also a colleague: Dr. Bright,
and SCP-963.
The monitor attached to the computer running
the simulation showed a curious, surprising
picture.
There was a door, with one sign: "Bright Council
Meeting Inside."
Past the door was a long conference table
packed to the brim with different attendees.
There were guards, D-Class, scientists, men
and women, all wearing the trademark anomalous
amulet.
It was every single incarnation of the Doctor
himself, all talking over each other with
great enthusiasm.
At the head of the table there was a monitor,
depicting the current incarnation of Dr. Bright
going about his daily life on a live video
feed.
All of the many, many Dr. Brights were instructing
him, giving him advice and guidance on every
impulsive decision.
Some Dr. Brights were brandishing pies, others
chainsaws, and others were drawing schematics
for laser guns and catapults.
The Council of Brights was working together,
devising pranks, schemes, and general tomfoolery.
The research team all agreed that Dr. Bright
could never learn about this simulation result,
lest he try to recreate it himself.
Next, they input details about SCP-5094, Ms.
J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse, the anomalous computer
program capable of teaching anyone about any
subject.
With a triumphant beep, the computer announced
that it had rendered a simulation of Ms. J's
pocket dimension might be.
It was a classroom, decorated in bright colors
and cutouts of various numbers and letters.
On the wall, motivational portraits were displayed
including kittens grabbing on to the rungs
of a ladder with the slogan: "Hang in there!"
There were bookshelves all along the walls,
filled to the brim with books.
At the chalkboard, a three-dimensional version
of Ms. J herself was standing with her signature
ponytail and bright green vest, piece of chalk
in her hand.
The desks were all empty, but she had a chipper
smile on her face, and was waiting for students
to come in and learn any minute.
On the board, she had written: "Welcome, class!"
Next, they chose an entity whose inner life
was a bit more difficult to discern, whose
motivations, though seemingly straightforward,
were perplexing.
SCP-049, the Plague Doctor, forever in pursuit
of curing a Pestilence that he could not get
the Foundation to understand, creating lifeless
zombies whenever he attempted to treat a patient.
Where would this inscrutable Doctor disappear
to, if he only could?
What would his hideaway be?
The simulation rendered a sterile laboratory
environment, no real surprise given his proclivity
for medical science.
There were stainless steel tables and instruments.
The Plague Doctor stood in the fully outfitted
lab, going about his work as he always did,
with no one to interrupt or disturb him.
On a desk in the corner sat a pile of medical
texts, a vase filled with lavender flowers
in fresh water, and a generous glass of rich
red wine.
There was everything here that he could possibly
need.
What about a pocket dimension for an entity
that already had everything it could possibly
want?
Something so content, so happy with its everyday
life, that it had no need or desire to escape?
SCP-999 lived as a pampered pet, a sort of
Foundation mascot, with its every wish for
tasty treats or playtime met.
Still, they input the Tickle Monster's information
into the simulation, to see what it might
come up with.
What it rendered looked like something out
of Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory.
It was a wide-open field beneath a bright
blue sky filled with sunlight and fluffy white
clouds.
The landscape, however, was not the greenery
and nature one might expect to see, but instead
was made up entirely of candy and other sweets.
Boulders made of toffee, a lake of melted
chocolate, lollipop trees, and cotton candy
bushes as far as the eye could see.
Nestled within the candy landscape was an
elaborate playground, more of an amusement
park than the usual row of swings and a plastic
slide.
There was a miniature Ferris wheel, a ball
pit, and an obstacle course that SCP-999 could
bounce around and navigate.
Every simple, childlike joy was present in
this place.
Pure sweetness, happiness, and light.
For a creature as good as SCP-999, they would
expect nothing less.
Next up was the deadly statue that moved only
when out of sight, SCP-173.
It took the researchers a moment to understand
what they were seeing when they took a look
at its dimension, at first they thought that
perhaps the simulation had somehow crashed.
After all, they were looking at a pitch-black
screen.
Then, they realized.
They were seeing what its dimension would
look like after all.
The perfect place for SCP-173 to retreat to
would be somewhere cloaked in absolute darkness,
where no one could keep an eye on the statue
and stop it from moving as it pleased.
Here, it would be free to hunt and take lives
as much as it wanted, keeping unsuspecting
humans in suspense as they waited for the
sound of grinding stone to betray that the
end was near.
The researchers all shuddered, and glanced
over their shoulders, just in case.
Since they were already feeling unsettled,
they decided to take it one step further and
see what SCP-682 might create for itself.
What could be home for the creature that hates
everything?
They were horrified to see a bleak, stony
landscape where the massive reptile was devouring
everything in sight.
Humans, plants, animals, none were safe from
being snapped up in its deadly jaws.
That wasn't the worst of it, though.
When it had finished consuming everything,
SCP-682 opened its mouth and coughed all of
its victims back up, miraculously resurrected
and unharmed.
Then, it began to do it all over again, ripping,
tearing, and clawing at all the living things
around it in an endless cycle of despair.
One researcher began to feel sick, and had
to flee the room.
The rest pressed on, if a bit paler than they
had been moments before.
Since the vibes in the room were already as
bad as they could possibly get, one researcher
suggested they keep the momentum going and
try out another highly hostile anomaly: the
possessive mask itself, SCP-035.
What sort of cursed reality could the simulation
come up with for the malicious mask, a being
that, though it couldn't move on its own,
seemed to radiate an almost unstoppable evil?
The monitor showed a rendering of an ornately
decorated castle with a Medieval European
sensibility: gold decor and rich red velvet
curtains, dots of black and red like blood,
and black goo on everything.
On the walls, elaborate tapestries were hung
depicting the traditional comedy and tragedy
masks that SCP-035 resembled.
There was a stained glass window toward the
back of the room, depicting SCP-035, with
a full human body, sitting atop a golden throne,
a crown on its head.
In the very center of the room, there was
SCP-035, in a position matching the stained
glass window.
At its feet, dozens of people dressed in rags
were kneeling in supplication to their ruler.
The mask was smiling.
Of course, that awful thing would want to
make itself the king of its own private castle,
forcing others to serve it every whim.
Time to shift gears to something completely
different.
SCP-2662, also known as Cthulhu.
Despite the creature's intimidating appearance,
he was overall a relatively polite being.
What would his chosen sanctuary look like?
SCP-2662's simulated pocket dimension was
a far cry from the luxury of SCP-035's.
There were no riches here, no opulent displays
of wealth and power.
It was the opposite.
The room depicted resembled a standard studio
apartment with a bed, a couch, a television,
and a kitchenette.
Every up-to-date game console - and some that
didn't exist yet - could be seen throughout
the room, and posters for various video games
and action and sci-fi movies adorned the walls.
There were stacks and stacks of games ready
to be played, as well as an extra-large bean
bag chair positioned directly in front of
the TV screen.
There, SCP-2662 sat, gaming happily.
The room had no windows, and no visible door
either.
No way for strangers to intrude on his peaceful
private leisure time.
Up next on the list was SCP-953, the Polymorphic
Humanoid.
But when the simulation rendered her pocket
dimension, she was nowhere to be seen.
There was a beautiful landscape, like something
out of a painting, of what appeared to be
an idyllic location in rural Korea.
There was vibrant green grass, a light blue
sky dotted with delicate wisps of cloud, and
a clear trickling stream.
There was a man lying by the stream, basking
in the sunlight, though he didn't look like
any anomaly the research team recognized.
They were checking him for the telltale fox
ears or tail that indicated a shapeshifted
SCP-953, when suddenly a figure emerged from
the water.
A woman with long dark hair, wearing a white
dress, and with those oh-so-familiar ears
poking out from her scalp.
She stretched her sharp claws wide, and snapped
her fingers.
Suddenly, the landscape changed.
The sky went dark, the clouds replaced with
fox's eyes glaring down from the heavens,
the stream flowed red with blood, and the
grass became a carpet of gnarled orange fur.
The man scrambled to his feet in a desperate
bid for escape, but SCP-953 jumped on him
before he could take so much as a step away
from her, and began to torture him gleefully.
The screen went red, as if with blood.
The Researchers definitely needed a palate
cleanser after that nightmarish vision, so
they selected a much more wholesome entity
from the list for the next round.
SCP-2295, the Patchwork Bear that so deeply
wanted to heal the world and help the sick
and hurting.
Its simulated dimension resembled an ordinary
doctor's office waiting room, with chairs,
a check-in desk, and some toys and books for
bored patients of all ages.
There was one difference, however: everything
in the room was made from scrap fabric and
yarn, materials the bear could use to patch
a potentially infinite number of troubles.
This was a place where the bear could bring
anyone in need of its help, and treat them
to the best of its ability.
But what about an anomaly that was not sentient,
or at the very least, one whose sentience
was very much up for debate?
The team selected SCP-914 for the next simulation.
Inputting the details of SCP-914, or the Clockworks,
resulted in an image of a small factory with
large metal doors.
Inside, all manner of unidentifiable machinery
worked in tandem to rearrange and reconfigure
various items.
There were different conveyor belts, each
marked according to one of the Clockworks'
settings: Coarse, Rough, 1:1, Fine, and Very
Fine.
Perhaps, one researcher posited, this particular
pocket dimension was not theoretical at all.
Maybe this was where items went when they
disappeared into the machine's intake booth?
Then again, who could be certain how exactly
an item like SCP-914 really worked?
Next was SCP-073, Cain.
In his dimension, the world of his own making,
he strolled through a dense forest, the vegetation
thriving all around him where it would have
ordinarily withered and died.
He plucked an apple off of a tree, and took
a bite.
SCP-529, Josie the Half Cat, romped through
a playroom that could only be described as
"cat heaven."
Scratching posts, fish and chicken treats,
balls of yarn, everything a feline friend
could ever desire.
One researcher wiped a tear from her eye,
and when her colleagues questioned it, she
just replied, "I really like cats, okay?!"
In a subject change, another Researcher suggested
trying a sort of "before and after" experiment
with the simulation.
They would see what sort of pocket dimension
might be generated by an anomaly before a
traumatic event, and what it might create
after.
They settled on SCP-066, Eric's Toy.
First, they built the simulation around SCP-066
as it first behaved when it arrived at the
SCP Foundation.
The result produced was a world made of colorful
yarn, filled with living yarn creatures roaming
about the landscape as Eric's Toy rolled around
among them cheerfully.
Then, they input the details of the incident
that shifted the entity's behavior, when a
D-Class attempted to cut off a piece of its
yarn body for study.
The resulting pocket dimension was made, not
of yarn, but of fleshy tendrils dripping with
red that curled and writhed like tentacles,
grasping and squeezing aggressively at anything
that intruded on the space.
A striking visual representation of the chance
in the anomaly's mental and emotional state.
Next was SCP-1867, Lord Blackwood.
Lord Blackwood's pocket out of reality was
the interior of a grand hunting lodge, with
a roaring fire in the fireplace and an impressive
- if a bit macabre - bear skin rug stretched
across the floor.
Lord Blackwood stood, in all of his brightly-colored
sea slug glory, at a bar in the corner of
the room next to a glass of whiskey and a
hand-carved wooden pipe.
All along the wall were various trophies,
taxidermy of a variety of wild beasts that
the slug had hunted over the years, as well
as artifacts picked up along its travels:
fossils, rare books, paintings, and primitive
weapons.
There were also grainy old photographs of
Lord Blackwood with many of his associates
from over the years, other famed hunters and
gentleman explorers he had embarked on his
expeditions alongside.
SCP-4910, the Grinner, would dwell in a volcanic
landscape, where rock and lava were replaced
with fleshy pink gums and teeth jutted out
of every available surface.
Gnarly.
SCP-076, Able, would use his pocket dimension
as a battle arena, a grand coliseum of sorts
filled with every weapon imaginable, where
he could trap his strongest would-be opponents
and force them into a fight to the death.
SCP-527, Mr. Fish's simulated pocket world
resembled the city of Boston, with one notable
difference: every depiction of a human being,
from statues to billboard advertisements to
magazine covers, showed them with fish heads
atop their human bodies.
There was not a human head to be seen, except
at what would have ordinarily been the seafood
market.
There, chests of ice held fresh human heads
ready to be sold.
Though the sight of the human heads was a
bit disconcerting, the research team understood
the significance of this place.
It made sense that Mr. Fish would want to
retreat to a world that matched his lived
experience, where everyone else looked like
him.
There was even a hat shop stocked with tiny
little formal hats like his very own tophat.
If SCP-2800, Cactusman, had a place between
realities that belonged exclusively to him,
it would be an underground superhero hideout.
The room depicted on the monitor resembled
the Bat Cave, but with all of the bats-themed
decor replaced with cactus-themed items instead.
There were also several large saguaro cacti
planted in pots throughout the space, as well
as several Cactus Man costumes in glass cases,
ready to be worn.
SCP-294, the Coffee Machine, would have a
secret world filled with every liquid substance
known to man, and several still undiscovered,
floating through the air but somehow never
mixing together.
Any beverage anyone could ever ask for would
be there, just waiting for the right order
to come in.
SCP-352, Baba Yaga, was next.
It was a large forest, seemingly ordinary
at first glance, but within its depths lurked
every fear a person could ever have, depending
on what unsuspecting victim she was able to
pull into the darkness.
There could be a high-up cliffside waiting
for someone afraid of heights, a giant spider
awaiting an arachnophobe, or thick, inky blackness
waiting for someone afraid of the dark.
All around the forest floor, her hair curled
waiting to ensnare her prey.
SCP-662, more specifically, SCP-662-1, Mr.
Deeds, quite possibly already occupied a pocket
dimension when his bell was not in use.
Though they had no way to know for certain,
the simulation predicted that his break room
of sorts might look like this: a blue room
with two shelves filled with cleaning tools,
a brown couch, and a little bed in the corner
where the butler could sleep during his time
off.
SCP-169, Leviathan, would disappear into an
aquatic pocket dimension, a place large enough
for it to swim comfortably, possibly forever,
in the peaceful infinite ocean.
Then, the research staff decided to input
SCP-096 and see what the Shy Guy's pocket
dimension might look like.
Unlike the Old Man, this anomaly was not aggressive
all the time, and it seemed to take no pleasure
in hunting.
Instead, it acted in a kind of twisted self-defense,
attacking anything that saw its face and set
it off on a spree of violence that ended in
death.
SCP-096's potential pocket dimension was a
dark, dismal labyrinth, like something out
of the Greek myth of the Minotaur.
Stone corridors twisted this way and that,
leading any potential intruders down dead
ends and away from the center, where SCP-096
hid from sight.
In the center, there was light and life, trees,
grass, a small pond, and a nest filled with
blind birds chirping and singing to SCP-096
as it sat in complete obscurity, away from
prying eyes.
We'd like to thank Cortex Vortex, Stonewood
Studios, Maddie H, ItsJustError, Tabs, GhostFang
12, Shadow623, River Man, Cheat Code Master,
Amanda Panda, Crimson Goregutter, Olivia Nealer,
Magenta Melon, ChaosPawn, Guy in a hole, JJJJ,
isabella gray, ryukaze20, Jay Enlow, LeoWorld,
UtterBrat, Joseph Gardner, Hollow, The Spark,
Ty, and Dinotime with Dinomike, and Corvus
for your help with this video!
Keep an eye on our community tab to be part
of the next one!
Now go check out “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks
SCP-106” and “SCP-096 VS SCP-106” for
more crazy what ifs involving a certain slimy
old man!